Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute
Papers with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we are going to see how NVIDIA’s light
transport algorithm can render this virtual
amusement park that contains no less than
3.4 million light sources interactively.
Yes. Millions of light sources.
How is this even possible? Well, to
understand what is going on here,
we need to talk about two concepts.
If we wish to create a truly photorealistic scene,
in computer graphics, we usually reach out to a
light transport simulation algorithm, and then,
this happens. Oh yes, concept number one. Noise!
This is not photorealistic at all, not yet anyway.
Why is that? Well, during this process, we have to
shoot millions and millions of light rays into
the scene to estimate how much light is bouncing
around, and before we have simulated enough rays,
the inaccuracies in our estimations show up as
noise in these images. This clears up over time,
but it may take from minutes to days for this to
happen, even for a smaller scene. For instance,
this one took us 3 full weeks to finish. Weeks!
Ouch. And in a moment, you will see that NVIDIA’s
technique can render even bigger scenes than this,
not in weeks, but in milliseconds.
Yes, really. I am not kidding.
And for now, concept number two. Biased
and unbiased. There are different classes
of light transport algorithms. Here you see an
unbiased technique that doesn’t cut any corners,
and now, look! Oh yes, this is a
biased technique, and as you see,
this one can give us a much cleaner
image in the same amount of time. But,
the price to be paid for this is that
some corners have been cut in the process.
And with that, now, hold on to your papers,
and have a look at NVIDIA’s technique.
Oh yes, this was the scene with
the 3.4 million light sources,
and this method can really render not just an
image, but an animation of it interactively.
That is absolutely incredible, and
it has even more to offer. Look!
The light sources can even be dynamic, or in
other words, they can move around as they please,
and the algorithm still doesn’t break a sweat.
Oh my goodness! That is absolutely amazing.
Now, let’s see how it compares to a previous
technique. Oh boy. See the noise levels here? This
is so noisy, we don’t even know what the scene
should exactly look like. But, now, when we have
a look at this technique, oh yes, now we know
for sure that there are some glossy reflections
going on here. Even the unbiased version of the
new technique is significantly better in this.
However, look, if we are willing to let the
simulator cut some corners, this is the biased
version, and, oh my goodness! Those difficult
glossy reflections are so much cleaner! I love it.
This amusement park scene contains a total of over
20 million triangles, and once again, the biased
version of the new technique makes it truly a
sight to behold. And, this does not take from
minutes to days to compute, each of these images
were produced in a matter of milliseconds! Wow.
But it gets better! How? Well, the more
detailed comparisons in the paper reveal
that this method is 10 to a 100 times faster than
previous techniques, and it also maps really well
onto our graphics cards. Okay, but what is behind
all this wizardry? How is this even possible?
Well, the magic behind all this is a smarter
allocation of these ray samples that we have
to shoot into the scene. For instance,
this technique does not forget what we did
just a moment ago when we move the camera a
little and advance to the next image. Thus,
lots of information that is otherwise thrown away
can now be reused as we advance the animation.
Now note that there are so many papers out there
on how to allocate these rays properly, this field
is so mature, it truly is a challenge to create
something that is just a few percentage points
better than previous techniques. It is very hard
to make even the tiniest difference. And to be
able to create something that is 10 to a 100 times
better in this environment? That is insanity.
And, this proper ray allocation has
one more advantage. What is that?
Well, have a look at this. Imagine that you are
a good painter, and you are given this image.
Now your task is to finish it.
Do you know what this depicts?
Hmm…maybe. But knowing all the details of this
image is out of question. Now, look, we don’t have
to live with these noisy images, we have denoising
algorithms tailored for light simulations.
This one does some serious legwork with this noisy
input, but even this one cannot possibly know
exactly what is going on because there is so much
information missing from the noisy input. And now,
if you have been holding on to your papers so
far, now, squeeze that paper, because, look.
This technique can produce this image in the same
amount of time. Now we’re talking! Now, let’s give
it to the denoising algorithm, and…yes! We get
a much sharper, more detailed output. Actually,
let’s compare it to the clean reference image. Oh
yes, this is much closer. And the fact that just
one more paper down the line, we could go from
this to this absolutely blows my mind. So cool!
But wait, we noted that the biased version of the
technique cuts some corners. What is the price to
be paid for this? What are we losing here?
Well, some energy. What does that mean? It
means that the image it produces is typically
a little darker. There are other differences,
but usually, they are relatively minor,
making this an excellent tradeoff.
Adding it all together, this will be an excellent
tool in democratizing light transport algorithms,
and putting it into the hands of everyone.
And to think that years ago, we had this,
and now, we can get this running on a commodity
graphics card. I am truly out of words. The
pace of progress in computer graphics research is
nothing short of amazing. What a time to be alive!
Now, if you also got excited by this. Look here.
This is not an implementation of this paper,
but the first author also has a nice little
webapp where you can create interesting 2D
light transport situations with lots of
caustics. And the results are absolutely
beautiful. The link is available in
the video description. Check it out!
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!